[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian Sievers guten Abend
ihnen allen wer mal den Terror der Hamas
in Israel erleben musste hat gelernt zu
unterscheiden zwischen dem zischen einer
anfliegenden Rakete und dem dumpfen
Knall wenn sie abgefangen wird man
beginnt schnell auf genau diesen Knall
zu warten um dann aufzuatmen puh der
Hightech Abwehrschirm hat funktioniert
ähnliches wäre auch den Menschen in der
Ukraine zu wünschen nur ist deren
Situation und schon die Größe ihres
Landes nicht einfach mit Israel zu
vergleichen aber gegen raketenterror aus
Moskau sollen auch sie besser geschützt
werden das sei Priorität der NATO heißt
es heute auf dem Treffen der
Verteidigungsminister in Brüssel
Deutschland hat ein erstes
Flugabwehrsystem geliefert und das soll
nur der Anfang sein Gunnar Krüger
erklärt was diese abwehrwaffen wann
leisten können
wenn es eine konstante gibt in diesem
Krieg dann die die NATO ist nicht sie
will nicht Kriegspartei sein am
Nachmittag also trifft sich die Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe militärs- und Minister aus
fast 50 Staaten doch sie sind im
NATO-Hauptquartier sie vertreten
meistens NATO-Mitglieder und alle drängt
der Nato-Generalsekretär angesichts
russischer Raketen alles die Verbündeten
haben Luftabwehr geliefert aber wir
brauchen noch mehr wir brauchen
verschiedene Systeme mit kurzer und
langer Reichweite gegen ballistisch
Raketen gegen Marschflugkörper und
Drohnen
eins dieser Systeme kommt aus deutscher
Produktion heißt Iris t SLM und kostet
140 Millionen Euro dafür gibt es eine
Radaranlage einen Gefechtsstand
Raketenwerfer und ein Versprechen
Luftabwehr in einem Radius von 40
Kilometern gegen Drohnen und Raketen
das ist halt dann nicht wahnsinnig viel
man kann damit eine kleine Fläche oder
eine kleine Stadt schützen sobald sie
aber schon große Städte schützen möchten
müssen sie deutlich mehr Radarsysteme
haben weil die Städte selber ein Teil
des radarsignals abnehmen so schreibt
denn auch der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister das ist nur der
Anfang und wir brauchen mehr trotzdem
Danke an die Kollegin in Deutschland
die verkündet den Brüssel heute die
erste Lieferung von ihres Tee nicht ohne
Stolz aber eben mit Verzögerung zu dem
folgen drei weitere erst nächstes Jahr
das sind hochkomplexe hochmoderne
Systeme und die brauchen eine gewisse
Zeit aber wir tun alles damit es so
schnell wie möglich geschickt diese
Systeme kommen spät sie kommen langsam
ich weiß dass das mit
Produktionskapazitäten zusammenhängt
aber dennoch glaube ich muss man jetzt
alles unternehmen um schneller zu sein
die USA führen die Kontaktgruppe und
gehen voran auch sie versprechen zwei
Luftabwehrsysteme aber
weitere müssen auch sie erst noch
produzieren
wir bringen nun unsere Waffenindustrie
zusammen damit Sie dieses Thema bauen
die die Ukraine braucht ohne Abstriche
an unsere eigene Sicherheit
es ist der Einstieg in eine
Kriegsproduktion das Stakkato der
Luftabwehr ist der Klang eines Wettlaufs
wem geht zuerst die Munition aus
die gute Nachricht ist glaube ich dass
man sagen kann Russland wird keine
modernen Raketen mehr herstellen können
es verschießt gerade den Rest seines
Arsenals wenn ich irgendjemand anders
liefert wird Moskau irgendwann leer sein
das ist vielleicht nur eine Hoffnung auf
jeden Fall aber die in saporicia letzte
Nacht jede Nacht jede Rakete die nicht
einschlägt hilft der Ukraine im Wettlauf
mit Russland
Florian Neuhann beobachtet für uns das
nato-treffen genannt floriander stellt
sich ja so ein Gefühl ein dass die NATO
irgendwie hinterherhingt auch jetzt beim
Abwehrschirm der ja überhaupt erst
produziert werden müsste
ja in der Tat das ist ein merkwürdiger
Kontrast hier zwischen der Ministerin
Lambrecht die heute hier mit großem
Stolz diese gestern erfolgte Lieferung
des ersten von vier luftabwehrsystemen
präsentiert hat und dann der Lage in der
Ukraine wo ein solches Abwehrsystem
eigentlich vor Wochen schon Leben hätte
retten können wo man von seit Wochen
darauf wartet die Ministerin erklärt
diese lange Laufzeit von der Verkündung
des Plans im Juni bis zur Lieferung
jetzt des ersten Systems im Oktober
stets mit Verweis auf die Industrie ich
glaube sie machte sich ein bisschen zu
einfach und ein bisschen Schuld liegt
auch bei der Politik die erstens kaum
langfristig plant in diesem Konflikt und
die zweitens immer erst dann reagiert
wenn Putins mit einer nächsten
Eskalation sie dazu quasi zwingt man
muss aber auch der deutschen
Bundesregierung vor allem zugute halten
von wo sie eigentlich herkommt manche
erinnert sich vielleicht dass dieselbe
Ministerin noch Anfang des Krieges damit
großem Stolz von den 5000 Helmen
gesprochen hat jetzt also eine
Luftabwehrsystem das nicht einmal in
Deutschland für sich selbst besitzt und
das ist dann doch eine ziemlich en eine
Steigerung und dann Florian Stichwort
langfristige Perspektive dann soll es ja
noch ein europäischen Schutzschirm geben
also für uns alle hier in Europa wie
weit ist denn diese Idee gedient
na sie wird immer konkreter vor sechs
Wochen hat der Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
in Prag erstmals öffentlich davon
gesprochen morgen nun wird im NATO
Hauptquartier hier in Brüssel eine
Absichtserklärung unterzeichnet die
Bundesregierung hat 13 weitere
EU-Staaten vor allem aus Osteuropa für
dieses Projekt gewinnen können also für
einen gemeinsamen Raketenabwehrschirm
über Europa
und ein eu-deponat mit dem wir heute
sprach der war bereits ganz euphorisch
und sprach davon dass 2025 dieses
Projekt bei bereits Realität werden
könnte ich glaube dazu gehört noch sehr
viel Fantasie denn es ist morgen nur
eine Absichtserklärung bei der noch
viele Fragen offen sind vor allem die
wohl ganz entscheidende nämlich die wäre
das eigentlich alles bezahlen soll
interessanter Analyse aus Brüssel
Florian danke dir wie sehr die Ukraine
auf moderne Raketenabwehr angewiesen
wäre das zeigt sich seit dieser Woche
noch mal ganz extrem am Montag hat es ja
eine ganze russische Angriffswelle
gegeben auch so heftig wie nie zuvor auf
die Innenstadt von Kiew dort mitten in
Kiew im Präsidentenpalast einem
Architektur Ungetüm aus sowjetagen
hinter Sandsäcken und schwer bewaffneten
Elite Soldaten sitzt wohl oder mir
silenski der Mann der Politik und
Strategie seines Landes vorgibt und
gleichzeitig für Durchhaltevermögen und
Überlebenswillen steht und dort hat der
zdf-reporterin Katrin Eugendorf heute
ein exklusives Interview gegeben
gestern haben sie gesagt danke
Deutschland danke Herr Scholz erstmals
haben sie sich so ausdrücklich bedankt
hat sich ihre Einstellung zu Deutschland
geändert
meine Einstellung zu Deutschland war
immer positiv denn ich habe die
Unterstützung der Gesellschaft von
Anfang an erlebt
seit Beginn dieser illegalen Besatzung
war die deutsche Gesellschaft
geschlossen und unterstützte
mehrheitlich die Ukraine ihren Kampf für
Recht und Freiheit deshalb hat sich
meine Haltung zu Deutschland nicht
geändert sondern die gesamte Einstellung
zu diesem Krieg hat sich geändert
sowohl beim Kanzler Scholz mir und uns
gegenüber als auch bei uns gegenüber
Herrn Scholz ich finde das ist ein
positiver Moment
yes
Präsident silensky Stuttgart
ist sehr wichtig ihre Argumente alles
hängt von Ihnen ab
ist eine sehr große Verantwortung
wahrscheinlich ist es auch die Rolle
eines Staatsoberhaupts denn leider oder
zum Glück eher leider ohne derartige
Herausforderung wie ein Krieg kann
glaube ich keine Führungspersönlichkeit
verstehen was die Wahl des Volkes
bedeutet
was es heißt Präsident zu sein oder
Kanzler oder
Ministerpräsident
wahrscheinlich versteht man diese
Verantwortung nicht ganz nicht
vollständig
der Krieg entblößt diesen Nerv und zeigt
ganz klar was es heißt führen zu müssen
und man muss diese Fähigkeit zu Führen
beibehalten
um das Land zusammenzuhalten
damit die Nation überleben kann
wir befinden uns jetzt in einer neuen
Etappe dieses Krieges die Ukraine hatte
große Erfolge und findet große
Unterstützung bürgt es nicht auch ein
Risiko Russland so zu einer Reaktion zu
provozieren dass sie womöglich zu
Atomwaffen greifen
[Musik]
ich möchte sagen
dieses Risiko hängt nicht ab von einer
schwachen Position Deutschlands
verstehen Sie
dieses Risiko hängt nicht von der
Position Europas ab
ausgebuddelt werden Angst haben zu
dieser oder jener Waffe zu greifen wenn
sich alle in Europa eindeutig stark
fühlen
wenn Sie verstehen dass es unmöglich ist
sie zu bedrohen egal womit
ein Besatzer muss eindeutig politisch
isoliert werden und wir sagen nicht dass
man das gleiche tun sollte was die
Russen tun keinesfalls
denn er führt sich auf wie ein Terrorist
so sollte sich Europa nicht benehmen
Europa ist anders aber es darf keine
Schwäche zeigen gegenüber dieser Führung
Russlands
stoppen
allen ist doch klar er wird sich Stück
für Stück nehmen schwache Positionen
Europas gegenüber Russland werden
Russland die Möglichkeit geben zu allen
möglichen Waffen zu greifen denn es gäbe
keine Folgen
man sah die Folgen der Besatzung der
Krim es gab sie nicht es gab nur sehr
oberflächliche Sanktionen ehrlich gesagt
das gab ihm die Möglichkeit anstatt
aufzuhören er war vorgewarnt er hat ja
gesehen dass nicht viel passiert
weiterzumachen es gab keinen Gegenschlag
und darin liegt das Problem
weiter hat unseren Donbass teilweise
einverleibt es gab keinen Gegendruck
nichts die Sanktionen waren
durchscheinend
er ging noch weiter schauen Sie was
anschließend in der Energiebranche
passiert ist
auf alle seine Schritte vorwärts machte
Europa Schritte zurück
mein Mantel man sah ihm entgegengetreten
aber in solch einer Art von Umarmung
wird Russland Europa drücken
das ist das Ziel dieser russischen
Führung ich sage nicht der russischen
Menschen sondern deren Führung die
Menschen in Russland sind leider zu
Informationen Zombies geworden
es braucht einen langen Weg der
Reintegration aber das ist deren Sache
ich möchte von der Führung sprechen und
deshalb falls er zu Atomwaffen greifen
sollte würde es nur dann dazu kommen
wenn er wüsste dass der Einsatz von
Kernwaffen keine Folgen nach sich zöge
und das komplette Gespräch mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten können Sie sich
anschauen in der ZDF Mediathek und auf
ZDF heute im Netz und jetzt erst ein
erster Überblick über weitere
Nachrichten und den hast du gute la im
Zusammenhang mit der Explosion auf der
krimbrücke hat Moskau 8 Personen
festnehmen lassen laut russischem
Geheimdienst sind davon fünf Russen drei
Personen stammten aus der Ukraine und
Armenien der FSB schreibt den Anschlag
dem ukrainischen Geheimdienst zu Kiew
weiß die Vorwürfe strikt zurück bei der
Detonation am Samstag kamen vier
Menschen ums Leben die Brücke verbindet
Russland und die 2014 von Moskau
annektierte Halbinsel Krim
das umkämpfte ukrainische Atomkraftwerk
saporicia ist binnen weniger Tage erneut
zeitweise von der externen
Stromversorgung abgeschnitten worden die
stillgelegten Reaktoren und die
nuklearen Brennstofflager in dem
russisch besetzten AKW mussten wieder
mit Notstrom aus Dieselgeneratoren
gekühlt werden in Polen ist ein Leck an
der aus Russland kommenden Ölpipeline
durch Bar entdeckt worden Ursache ist
nach polnischen Angaben eine
unbeabsichtigte Beschädigung laut
Bundesregierung ist die Versorgung in
Deutschland nicht gefährdet
nach den sabotage-angriffen auf die
nord-stream Pipelines und das
Kommunikationsnetz der Deutschen Bahn
wird über einen besseren Schutz
kritischer Infrastruktur diskutiert im
Innenausschuss des Bundestages forderte
grünen Obmann Emmerich konkrete
Antworten und Konzepte Innenministerin
Faeser Versicherte das von der Ampel
vereinbarte Gesetz werde noch in diesem
Jahr auf den Weg gebracht
die EU plant weitere Sanktionen gegen
Iran offiziell sollen sie kommenden
Montag von den EU-Außenministern
beschlossen werden Reaktion auf das
harte Vorgehen des iranischen Regimes
gegen die Proteste im ganzen Land auch
heute gab es in mehreren iranischen
Städten Kundgebungen erneut
demonstrierten Studentinnen und
Schülerinnen auch gegen den
Kopftuchzwang der islamischen Regierung
die Verkehrsminister von Bund und
Ländern beraten erneut über eine
bezahlbare Nachfolgelösung für das 9
euro-ticket hoch umstritten ist
weiterhin die Finanzierung die Länder
verlangen deutlich mehr Unterstützung
vom Bund im Gespräch ist dabei ein 49
Euro Ticket für den Nahverkehr
Ergebnisse der Verkehrsministerkonferenz
sind für morgen angekündigt
für einen Innenminister ist er zu früh
und zu unbesorgt ins Bett gegangen in
der katastrophennacht für einen
Innenminister hat er zu wenig gewusst
als seine Bürger mit gewaltigen
Wassermassen kämpften wobei nicht ganz
klar ist ob er wirklich zu wenig gewusst
hatte oder doch viel mehr wusste als er
bislang zugab heute hat der
rheinland-pfälzische Innenminister Roger
lewenz SPD seinen Rücktritt eingereicht
ein Abgang mit Ankündigung denn je
weiter die Aufarbeitung der
Flutkatastrophe im Aartal kommt desto
mehr wird klar dass Krisenmanagement der
Landesregierung war dieser Krise nicht
gewachsen und es gibt auch nach diesem
Tag heute noch viele Fragen wie Christel
Haas zeigt
da stehen sie der noch Innenminister und
seine Ministerpräsidenten ihre Minen
sprechen Bände jeder weiß was jetzt
kommt
heute übernehme ich für mein
Verantwortungsbereich gemachte Fehler
die politische Verantwortung
ich habe unseren Ministerpräsidentin sie
hat es eben ausgeführt um einen
Rücktritt als Staatsminister das
Minister des Innern und für Sport
angeboten es ist ein bitteres
Eingeständnis das in der flutnacht das
Krisenmanagement nicht funktionierte
scheibchenweise waren in den letzten
Wochen neue Informationen ans Licht
gekommen diese Aufnahmen einer
Hubschrauberstaffel zeigen dass die Lage
an der a-katastrophal war Häuser stehen
bis zur Dachrinne unter Wasser Bewohner
senden verzweifelte Lichtsignale die
Bilder waren über ein Jahr lang
verschollen nicht aber der
Einsatzbericht der Piloten der lag dem
Lagezentrum in der Nacht vor und damit
auch belastbare Informationen über das
Ausmaß der Flut
noch heute über ein Jahr danach sind die
Schäden im Aartal deutlich sichtbar und
immer noch ist die Frage präsent hätten
Menschenleben weiterfluss abwärts
gerettet werden können wenn früher
gewarnt worden wäre eine Bürgermeisterin
hatte damals früh Alarm geschlagen wurde
nicht gehört jetzt ist die Landrätin und
sieht im Minister Rücktritt eine neue
Chance für den Kreis ist das
unter anderem das Signal und die
Hoffnung dass die Geschehnisse gut
analysiert werden können um daraus zu
lernen vor allem auch für den
Katastrophenschutz auf Landesebene und
auch länderübergreifen zu lernen bei der
Opposition in Mainz scheint es so als
würde man den Abgang des Ministers noch
einmal nachstellen doch es ist nur ein
sitzplatzmissverständnis
unmissverständlich ist aber die Reaktion
das Thema sei noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen
sein Rücktritt erfolgt nicht aus
persönlicher Einsicht sondern wegen der
erdrückenden Beweislage im
Untersuchungsausschuss wir sind noch
lange nicht am Ende wir möchten wissen
warum die Regierung Dreier derart
versagte
und wo die Verantwortlichkeiten von Frau
Dreier liegen die Landesregierung und
die flutnacht Menschen in höchster Not
die nicht gehört wurden Versäumnisse
Fehler und ein Krisenmanagement das
Fragen aufwirft und der Druck bleibt die
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt der
Untersuchungsausschuss in Mainz ist
weiter auf der Suche nach Antworten
400.000 neue Wohnungen bauen jedes Jahr
das Ziel war schon ohne Energiekrise
ehrgeizig ohne Baustoff Knappheit und
ohne Fachkräftemangel jetzt ist es
ehrgeiziger denn je aber die
Bundesregierung hält daran fest
Wohnungen sind wichtig und rar und immer
weniger zu bezahlen an Bedarf hat sich
also nichts geändert den neuen widrigen
Umständen will der Staat jetzt begegnen
mit einem ganzen Bündel von Maßnahmen
wie Andrea Maurer berichtet
diese Baulücke steht sinnbildlich für
Deutschlands Mangel 62 Sozialwohnungen
sollten hier in Dresden entstehen der
Bau wurde aus Kostengründen gestoppt
anderer Ort Berlin-Neukölln die
Sozialwohnungen hier werden noch gebaut
für den Bauleiter aber ist das
Stadtquartier längst ein Verlustgeschäft
wir haben eine baukostensteigerung von
annähernd 25 Prozent jeder der einen
Zettel beschreiben kann schreibt drauf
baukostenerhöhung des für uns alle sehr
dramatisch überall in der Republik
verschärft der Krieg in der Ukraine eine
Lage die ohnehin schlecht war der
Kanzler und die bauministerin wissen das
an ihrem Ziel 400.000 neue Wohnungen pro
Jahr davon hunderttausend
Sozialwohnungen halten Sie beim
wohngipfel heute trotzdem fast stoisch
fest
gerade auch wenn jetzt die Zeiten viel
schwieriger werden um das Ziel zu
erreichen ist es richtig dass wir das
tun denn nichts hat sich geändert an der
Bedarf der Bürgerinnen und Bürger neue
Wohnung zu haben bezahlbare Wohnung zu
haben in diesem Sinne war das heute ein
ganz wichtiger Zwischenschritt es ist
nicht das Ende des Prozesses das Ende
des Prozesses ist erst erreicht wenn wir
die Kapazitäten im Baubereich in
Deutschland so erhöht haben dass wir
400.000 Wohnungen schaffen können
Kanzler und Ministerin werden sich an
ihren Ziel messen lassen müssen und an
dem was sie heute mit Vertretern aus
Wirtschaft Politik Zivilgesellschaft
festgeschrieben haben unter anderem das
was schon im Frühjahr in der Regierung
vereinbart wurde 14,5 Milliarden für den
sozialen Wohnungsbau bis 2026 außerdem
Förderung von Umnutzung Dachausbauten
und Aufstockungen Begrenzung von
Baukosten zum Beispiel durch modulares
oder serielles bauen
manche Bündnispartner kritisieren schon
jetzt Mängel des Papiers dass sie
unterschrieben haben
wir haben einen Fachkräftemangel so dass
im Baumaßnahmen kaum noch fachgerecht
ausgeführt werden können und wir haben
massive länger Lieferengpässe gerade bei
den Technologien die wir in den
kommenden Monaten und Jahren brauchen
all diese Realitäten blendet das Bündnis
völlig aus das Problem ist die Menge des
Geldes Frau Ministerin Geiwitz hat bei
ihrem Kollegen Lindner zusätzlich was
locker gemacht was bestimmt nicht
einfach war aber dennoch reicht es nicht
weil offensichtlich die Privatinvestoren
noch immer keine Lust drauf haben
Sozialwohnungen zu bauen weil sie
offenbar errechnen dass es sich für Sie
noch nicht lohnt
was fehlt ist ein Wumms gestern hat die
bauministerin eine Plattform gestartet
mit der das Bauwesen digitaler werden
soll an der Lage wie sie aktuell ist
wird das erstmal nichts ändern
deutschland muss sich wohl auf Jahre des
wohnraummangels einstellen
und jetzt noch mal einen Blick nach vorn
und nochmal leider keine besonders
rosigen Aussichten Gundula Deutschland
steht vor einem Konjunktur Abschwung es
sein ernste Zeiten sagte
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck bei der
Vorstellung der aktuellen
Wirtschaftsprognose der Bundesregierung
die Energiekrise wachsen sich immer mehr
zu einer Wirtschaftskrise aus Valerie
Halle an der Börse womit müssen
Wirtschaft und Verbraucher konkret
rechnen ganz konkret mit
Wohlstandsverlust der alle aber
natürlich die unteren Einkommensgruppen
am härtesten trifft die explodierenden
Energiepreise erfassen nämlich
inzwischen ganz weite Teile des
Wirtschaftslebens ob jetzt Supermarkt
tanken oder der Besuch im Restaurant
vieles ist teurer geworden das dämpft
den Konsum und der ist natürlich eine
wichtige konjunkturstütze gleichzeitig
belasten die hohen Energiepreise auch
Unternehmen viele Firmen haben ihre
Produktionen zwischen heruntergefahren
weil sie eben nicht mehr rentabel ist
laut Bundesregierung bleibt die
Inflation auch erstmal hoch für dieses
Jahr rechnet sie mit einer Teuerungsrate
von 8 Prozent
2023 soll sie bei 7 Prozent liegen
düster auch die Aussichten auf die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung in diesem
Jahr soll es noch ein Wachstum von 1,4
Prozent geben doch für 2023 droht eine
Rezession minus 0,4 Prozent spürbar
besser wird es nach Ansicht der
Bundesregierung erst 2024 erst dann soll
sich die Inflation laut
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck wieder
weitgehend normalisieren die Börse
reagiert auf die regierungsprognose
nicht begeistert aber eben auch nicht
geschockt eine verheerende Prognose
reiht sich ja schließlich zur Zeit an
die andere heute gab es eine
alarmierende Nachricht noch von BASF der
Chemiekonzern meldet einen
Gewinneinbruch von fast 30 Prozent im
dritten Quartal bASF will nun massiv
Jahren und dafür sollen auch Stellen
wegfallen wie viele darüber macht der
chemie-riese allerdings keine Angaben
erst einmal danke Valerie für heute
wie erwartet nimmt eine neue
corona-welle Fahrt auf die Zahlen
steigen das Robert-Koch-Institut meldet
einen Anstieg der sieben Tage Inzidenz
auf knapp 800 und das ist deutlich mehr
als vor einer Woche Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach forderte die Länder auf eine
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen zu prüfen
insgesamt seit Deutschland aber sehr gut
auf eine neue Welle vorbereitet auch
wegen der angepassten Impfstoffe
Bundespräsident Steinmeier ist derzeit
im Rahmen seiner Gesprächsreihe Ortszeit
Deutschland in Neustrelitz in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die sorgende der
Menschen in der aktuellen Energiekrise
seien eines der drängsten Themen auf dem
Wochenmarkt in der strukturschwachen
Region Steinmeier führt noch bis morgen
seine Amtsgeschäfte in einem Hotel der
Stadt
die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch
lauten ohne Gewähr 16 21 26 35 48 49
Superzahl 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im zdftext auf Seite
ausgewählte Fußballspiele der
Frauen-Bundesliga werden ab der Saison
2023/24 live bei ARD und ZDF zu sehen
sein und die Länderspiele werden wie
bisher auch in den kommenden vier
Spielzeiten von beiden Sendern
übertragen die Vereinbarung mit dem DFB
werde so zdf-chefredakteurin Schausten
dem Frauenfußball in Deutschland einen
weiteren Schub verleihen
da freuen wir uns drauf und das war
unser Mittwoch im heute-journal danke
für Ihr Interesse um 0:45 Uhr meldet
sich später Christopher Wehrmann mit
unserem heute schon mal Update von uns
allen hier im heute schon mal Team an
sie einen angenehmen Abend tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt heißt es Abschied
nehmen vom goldenen Oktober denn dieses
hoch zieht ostwärts ab und Tiefs
übernehmen bei uns die wetterregie so
wird es wolkiger windiger wechselhafter
und etwas Regen fällt auch aber auch
über das Mittelmeer zieht ein Tief
hinweg und das wird bis Freitagabend
auch das östliche Mittelmeer auch Kreta
erreicht haben in dieser Nacht bildet
sich erstmal wieder dicker Nebel hier in
Süddeutschland und von Nordwesten kommen
schon die dichteren Wolken an zwischen
Berlin Brandenburg und dem östlichen
Sachsen bleibt es klar und da wird es
dann auch am kältesten da sinken die
Temperaturen in dieser Nacht auf drei
Grad dort droht also Bodenfrost sonst
liegen die Tiefsttemperaturen bei
milderen neun bis vier Grad und morgen
erwarten uns 13 Grad an der Ostsee auch
in Schleswig-Holstein oder hier im
Sauerland bis zu 19 Grad gibt es im
westlichen Sachsen am Vormittag kann
sich im Osten noch hier und da die Sonne
zeigen in Süddeutschland bleibt
allerdings zum Teil neblig trüb und von
Nordwesten kommen diese dichteren Wolken
heran die bringen Regen mit das ist gar
nicht so sehr viel Regen aber diese
Regenwolken weiten sich am Nachmittag
weiter nach Osten aus am längsten
trocken bleibt es wohl in Berlin
Brandenburg im östlichen Sachsen und
auch in Niederbayern am Freitag und am
Samstag ist es meist wechselhaft am
freundlichsten ist es wohl noch hier im
Nordosten und am Alpenrand kann es auch
mal länger regnen am Sonntag dann aber
gibt es doch für die meisten von uns
schon wieder mehr Sonnenschein bei
Temperaturen zwischen 15 und 23 Grad
guten Abend